as a graphic artist and as a rapper it's
not that AI is going to be better than
us that should be our concern because
there's people out there better than you
that don't have your careers and that's
just art and commerce you know your goal
is how to present this to people
[Music]
yo what's up guys I am Tom as dope as
Yola whatever you want to call me
welcome back to the dope as usual
podcast I'm here with my co-host Marty
O'Neill what's up guys we have a very
special episode today you guys know
except how excited I am talking about
this for five and a half months since we
found out we were in Chicago and I got
hyped up you guys know how important
this is today is a legendary episode
this is atmosphere and slug thank you
for being here thank you for having us
thanks for being here guys thanks for
having us on 4 20. I know of all days
wait am I allowed to drop the date yeah
okay yeah it's 4 20 of all it makes it
so much more historic for this episode
for us why do you are you guys like I
see like a bong and I like do you guys
talk about weed on this podcast uh so my
background is on YouTube I have the
biggest Wii channel in YouTube oh that's
what I do so I've been to a weave like
10 years probably I did not do my
research nah you're good because like if
you ever learned how to roll a joint
every time you're a struggling in high
school like I can't do this I'm there to
help you so I'm like I'm like Bob Ross
of weed for the next years now all right
so that's why we were like you know
let's transfer this [__] over and he was
doing like all the comedian podcasts the
rogans and all them he goes let's do our
own show here we are three years later
okay yeah yeah very excited so that's
our background well it's a it's a
pleasure for us to be here right now
with you guys thank you thank you thank
you real quick you always look John Wick
spiffy I want to say that right now when
you walked out I was like what is it was
like elegant as hell he's about to play
the piano yeah I think it's just uh
it's just
it builds my self-esteem to walk into a
place and and uh command respect to some
degree yes damn we're Advanced it's kind
of weird because everyone it's almost
like everywhere I go like um
people always at least treat me halfway
like yes sir I get off on that yeah it's
always been that way yeah yeah I got
called Sarah recently it was yeah I like
it you know but I've been getting that
for years decades yeah
and one other thing before we even get
started yo the Ned Flanders must
actually been rocking for for a while
now I like this whole identity he
reminds me of when I was a kid I used to
see that uh that Beastie Boys where they
had the mustaches on and they were
running at each other the sabotage
sabotage video yeah yeah yeah yeah thank
you I was probably influenced by that
yeah yeah yeah yeah because I saw we
went to thank you again for advice of
the show I think it was October we went
and that was at the Belasco yeah some
creepy ass place well you think so it's
mad creepy okay he's on the wall Mike
those old theaters I liked it yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that was that was
that was one of my one of my favorite
spots so far yeah oh I just thought
remember we're looking up like this I'm
gonna get possessed it's like super
Gothic Styles
um so one thing I want to say that show
I've been to you guys shows
Berkeley Oakland Santa Cruz all with
live bands though you guys all had live
bands and when I first walked on my live
band what is it and that was like 2008
2009 what got you guys to transition
into that because it was a straight you
and you going hard on a stage for years
correct and then you guys introduced
live band live music because that's when
I started seeing this there had already
been a lot of evolution going on with
the live performance like when it first
started actually it was me another MC
named spawn and uh that dude right there
was the DJ his name's stress and um from
there it just always people would come
and go in and out Aunt always was making
the Beats but he didn't want to be on
stage so I you you if it said atmosphere
you knew I was going to show up and
whoever else showed up with me you might
get idea you might get immersed you
might get Mr dibs you might you know you
just didn't know it was all about who I
could convince to roll with me you know
what I'm saying
um and then around 2005 live
I wanted to try doing a live band to see
if I could if that makes any sense but
also just to push to to switch things up
to to try to keep me from being too
comfortable whatever whatever you call
that kind of art evolution
um and at the same time coincidentally
Anthony was interested in becoming a
part of this as well and so we had a
live band in Anthony on stage in 2005
and then from there we still continue to
do different versions of the live band
along with Anthony on stage till he
basically reached a point where ant was
the drummer
he was keeping the Beats going and then
there was two dudes filling in you know
and then from there we thought how to
push further beyond that because with a
live band you have a lot of room for
error and that part was dope to me that
the fact that things could go wrong more
than just your needle break you're
comfortable I'm saying like yes ma'am
and and so
we figured out a way to do that with two
DJs and then using uh you know like
tracking on stage you know live live
tracking going on along with DJs to to
bring back that room for error to keep
the sound bigger and more open not so
linear to channel yeah I'm saying
because because coming from a live band
back to a DJ you have all these things
that you got to now consider it's like
oh the the sound goes like this again
when for a while there we were like a
wall of sound you feel me like so we
figure out how to do that with two DJs
and that excited me and that's where
we're at now you know I'm saying like
that's still kind of the version of what
we're working with now yeah when we saw
you I remember I said it no live band
because I've never seen like that show
you know as a fan you see all the clips
and everything and you wish like damn
that'd be sick I'm not saying the live
band is bad it was just when I saw just
you two up there and there was another
DJ right but I don't know and he's
I was trying to introduce him to you got
like to this culture in this world he
walked and go is it for real like I'm
like just wait main thing I noticed like
I grew up in music live shows my dad was
a musician and I grew up since I was a
little kid in the studio watching live
performances wasn't music super D myself
I've never felt that connection with all
the people in the room all the fans with
you up there with your super
introspective lyrics and everybody it
was just a different vibe than I've ever
felt at a live performance do you feel
like you have a really unique
relationship with your fans uh that's a
great question and and um I appreciate
the way you articulated that what I
think is going on in is that our fans
have that
experience with themselves and then when
you put them in a room with other people
who are looking for that then there's
now this community of that you know it's
not hit driven
um unfortunately uh my fault
but but more so it's it's driven by the
audience's relationship or experience to
the song and so when you do have those
people in a room together and I don't
think that's exclusive to us you know
what I'm saying like I think that that's
part there's a there's a there's a part
of us that look for that from our music
you know what I'm saying and so we're
fortunate that we have an audience that
they bring it into the room and then
they allow us to go on stage kind of
like maybe the
you know how at church there'll be a
band in the back with the organ yes they
allow us to be that but this is still
their church this is still their time to
let me put that kind of their time to to
to to find that thing that they've been
looking for you know plenty of people
got hits but not so many people around
for 20 years still touring and putting
out new music that Community is what we
want to get in there we got hits we got
hits yeah
um and I know what you're saying and I
appreciate that um yeah you know our I
think relationship to
this as well as to our audience as well
as to each other is is like just one you
said Bob Ross it's one big happy
accident you feel me it's like it's like
uh we just keep doing what we feel
is genuine to us and trying to do it as
best as possible and just hope it works
for everybody feel me hope I hope that
hope that this you know it's weird like
when we book a show
one of my concerns is Yo is everybody
gonna feel like they got their money's
worth because your concerts are
expensive now you know what I'm saying
and so it's like when I was a kid you go
see a show for seven bucks or something
you know what I mean like five now I
realize people are putting their
resources their time their money
babysitter babysitters you feel me like
you know it's a lot and so we still
have that type of uh for lack of a
better word insecurity of making wanting
to make sure everybody feels like they
got what they came for you know what I'm
saying and and I think stuff like that
helps keep pushing and inspiring us to
to treat it with that type of respect to
respect this the way that it shows it to
us you know not just our craft not just
what lyrics beats whatever but even the
relationship with the audience yeah and
respecting your sound you have such a
unique like authentic sound and even
sampling the new album a little bit like
listening to it thank you again
such appreciate unique and I love how
you really like brought back like long
songs really letting everything build up
into the song reminded me of Pink Floyd
honestly I used to let the song before
it comes in with all the instrumentation
and stuff I love that in hip-hop you
know no lie I when I when I called uh
the label and said hey we're working on
another record that was what I tried to
sell them I I tried to vote that's the
best this is gonna be our Pink Floyd
record so when you said that just now
listen I haven't even had the chance to
say that out loud to nobody yet besides
them so the fact that you called that
out is beautiful to me and obviously we
know we're not Pink Floyd but what I
what I interpret from what you're saying
is that you know we you might say over
thought what we were working on not we
weren't just coming from a place of
instinct or uh past experience or we
know how to do this or we have all that
all the things we've done we still carry
we still know how to do them and we do
them but also trying to figure out how
to apply new challenges to ourself new
you know I like to call them ceilings
new Easter eggs to hide new things to do
you know I felt like as we were making
this I felt like this was our version of
a of of a of a underground rap Pink
Floyd record you know but that's just
really me on my arrogant tip in the car
talking to the label like for you to say
that that feels void that status yeah
that feels really good yeah that feels
it's a Vibe it's in the production you
can hear it like how much time went into
that how much thought realities exist
simultaneously
[Music]
cold turkey might be great on sandwiches
but there's a better way to break your
bad habits it's fume they look at the
problem in a different way instead of a
drastic uncomfortable change why not
just remove the bad from your habits
fume is an Innovative award-nominated
device that does just that instead of
electronics fumes is completely natural
fume uses flavored Air instead of
harmful chemicals and I'm gonna be
honest every single flavor I tried is
bomb and they're all natural your fume
comes with an adjustable airflow dial
and is designed with movable parts and
magnets for fidgeting and stressful
situations honestly it tastes more
flavorful than I thought it would
stopping is something people put off
because it's hard but switching a fume
is easy fume has over a hundred thousand
customers and thousands of success
stories there's no reason the next one
can't be you so head over to trifum.com
that's
t-r-y-f-u-m.com and use our code Dau
that's going to get you 10 off of the
journey pack so go to try fum.com
trifum.com use code Dau and get an
additional 10 off your order today
[Music]
I watched the video uh okay first off I
love that MERS is the homeless man thank
you very much that was a great that was
awesome
um
I don't want to I mean I listen to I'm
not gonna start saying anything I
noticed that obviously as if they live
Vibe on that video that's what I got the
Roddy Piper movie that's kind of what I
felt on it yeah we're definitely John
Carpenter fans yeah yeah yeah I don't
know if that was necessarily the the
inspiration but it's totally in the
video and everybody's going like so
you're yeah yeah you're uh what is his
name NADA that's his name in the movie
so it's like so you're not a MERS is the
other homie that they're fighting I was
smoking I don't even know it's I only
know that it's Keith David and uh and
Roddy Roddy Piper I don't know any
character names I just know the actors
oh his name's NADA oh I only know that
because I bought the toy recently I go
what's what is Roddy Pipers and it says
NADA and they got the weirdest fight
scene at the ball best fight scene
that's nine minutes long yeah could be
to share each other in an alley over
some glasses I love it watch they live
um oh the reason I bring it up is you
get the alien theme going on I'm not
gonna spoil it I heard some more stuff
it reminded me not reminded me it gave
me the vibe of like
storytelling Deltron 30 30. I get to go
on a space adventure on this one that's
how I was kind of like because I told
you all the time when me and Marty met
Marty's very East Coast he grew up in
his you know your music your era like
that's and I'm over here like trying to
introduce him like yo this is the Living
Legends this is who these guys are this
is you know 3M you know what I mean like
I'm trying to introduce him to that and
I showed him Deltron 3030 and I know
obviously you wanted to be Dell I get
that you're a very big fan so I got this
this is
just instrumentals I found the Deltron
3030. I don't know if you have that I
have it you do have it
I don't think I have this then that's
yours I specifically don't have
yeah yeah no I don't I don't have the
instrumentals I got the full album yeah
we were just talking about this record
like yeah a week ago yeah we were just
talking about that yeah we just
delivered pizza and sell weed when I
deliver pizza that's that was my thing I
put all my my scale and my [__] in my
bag with pounds or whatever and I'd walk
up and we'd go in and no one would ever
suspect a [__] thing so I used to
listen to I used to buy CDs that's my
thing I buy CDs and street light records
of Santa Cruz next to
um The Catalyst you guys know that's
where you know and you guys played at
the uh Community Center downtown because
you guys obviously not enough people fit
in the Catalyst for you guys but that's
where I would buy all my stuff so that
record that's what it reminds me of like
just fun Underground
good times I I appreciate that thank you
thank you very much yeah
um but back to your album it releases
May 5th May 5th May the 5th be with you
May the 5th be with you there we go it's
gonna be oh is that what is that why you
kind of picked the alien theme no we
don't get just randomly man the label
tells us your record's coming out on
this day and you just go okay yes sir
thank you whatever you say Sir
um no May 5th was uh it was accidentally
fresh to be made accidentally fresh I
like that to be made I wake up
but I think I think it's I think more so
it was a matter of like when you can
line everything up when you turn an
album in at least for a group like us
you want to get vinyl vinyl right now
has got such a long lead time it takes a
long time to get vinyl pressed and so
you go okay so when can we have physical
pieces and then you try to line
everything up so it works together you
know what I mean obviously uh we got
lucky with the May the fifth be with you
I I wish that I thought I had to like I
don't know print a sticker or something
that said that because it kind of even
the concept of thinking like that fits
into the concept of the album uh yeah
you know what I mean so so that was just
accidentally fresh but I I wanted to say
something about the day live thing like
we weren't basing the video around that
but because that movie is such a had
such an imprint on
a certain part of the culture it is
already existing in our heads that movie
is and so once you get the video going
it became obvious like oh that is kind
of like they live people are gonna see
that I see it and it informs you as you
go everything that you watch or listen
to or read informs the art that you make
as well even when you don't realize it
so that's again accidentally fresh
really it's elf do you remember Alpha
the alien the alien what did the alien
always want to eat
and the alien was existing with this
family finding out how to assimilate
within this like American family and
that was basically the structure of the
show and so that was the idea for the
video
we were in a truck in the middle of
nowhere in Massachusetts and I just
started oh what if we did this and it
just came out you know what I mean and
then I was like let's make a video and
he was like he's like no don't do
concepts you just make [__] up that's
[__] awesome he was like no don't do
that and I was like no it's gonna be
fine and and I I still don't know if he
likes the video he might no no no I
don't like the video actually but I
don't like any of our videos really you
know what I mean I just I just are hard
after a while I look back and go oh
that's that's all right you know what I
mean it takes it's just
I just have a relationship with the
music that's made and then when it's
someone else's vision goes on it it's
like I wasn't thinking about that even
if it's my idea because there's a couple
of the videos over the years the even
the worst ones what's the worst one you
think we had this one video where um
he's playing that oh that video is
amazing
and it's the one we made it look like
it's like a like a song from the 70s
like American Bandstand style yeah yeah
yeah and I got I got mannequins this
video is amazing and that's the thing so
here's the thing
we're together that's already a
collaboration right I have a vision of
what it is he has a vision we see
different colors sometimes when we're
doing it we have different ideas of what
it is but we both know hey it means a
lot to both of us let's let other people
hear it well then sometimes you make a
video for those now you trust in another
person to have this Vision to go with it
and when you tie their Vision to yours
it can be real difficult if if you take
yours is it serious or if you nurture it
the way that that we do you know what I
mean so it's like it could be difficult
to I just I have to disconnect the two I
have to go I'm not even going to worry
about how is this video If this wasn't
mine would I watch it again what I'm
saying would we like it yeah yeah that's
the number one thing and that's how I
gotta see stuff like that because I
don't make videos for real and so I
don't know I'm really not good at
telling you what's fresh I can just tell
you what I like so trying to marry
somebody else's visuals to your music
that can be hit or miss you know yeah I
get what you're saying yeah because it's
not what you were in town when you were
thinking like oh yeah that's not what I
thought would happen during that
baseline or something I get it yeah I
just don't know how to separate myself
that with that stuff yet I still don't
so you're saying like I don't even like
how I was in the video I noticed like
you're not you just do a little quick
cameo in the video like I said you're
very like into the Shadows yeah yeah
yeah yeah I noticed that so
um I've I've watched so much you guys's
stuff you are very rarely even in
interviews no not too of very rare I
found one that you guys released when
life gives you lemons oh we made those
on our own yeah it would look like you
guys just shot it right yeah yeah I want
to be done with this video oh yeah he
doesn't like videos I feel I feel that
sometimes I get you yeah it's just uh
it's a insecurity stuff you know just
like seeing myself on like I'd be really
hard-pressed to imagine watching this
you know what I mean I will though for
the pain of it
but just how it is you know that's just
how my mind works and uh it just so
happens that with my career it's worked
out in a weird way that I don't do this
type of stuff too often or I'm not shown
in a lot of the pictures all the time
and it just comes in hand it comes in
handy a little yeah yeah well if it's
perfect man yeah if it works it works
yeah yeah one question or one thing when
life gives you lemons in two days would
be 15 years ago by the way oh [__] by
the way it'll be 15 years ago that it
released huh what he is doing exactly
when that happened when that album
dropped do you remember what you were
doing that day I was wearing some
horrible jeans remember yeah because I
yeah I guarantee I was I I if I were to
look no I don't remember I could just
saying okay I was wearing jeans that
were like too light and I was probably
wearing a a a button up with a little
collars golf I don't know what those
shirts are called Charlie Sheen shirts
American Apparel had them right and I
had like every color because I didn't
know how to dress so I would just be
like well I like that shirt let me buy
12 of them and then I still live like
that like I like aside from the hoodie
everything I'm wearing I've got like
multiple copies because I just don't
want to think about it you know I'm
saying like I'm Homer Simpson I'm not
like Ned Flanders bro like like you said
yeah yeah I'm all about dependable and
does it work if it works I'll drive it
you feel me like yeah yeah oh but I'm
the same way though I have like just
rows and rows of black polos you know
what I mean oh I could imagine they're
doing great great pants and [__] you
know what I mean like it's like a
different store is it the same thing
when you go into like approach a new
album between YouTube collaborating on
it like I'm not I wouldn't say how many
there's more than 20 tracks on this
album so I don't know if that means you
guys made a couple hundred where did you
make 25. not no more we don't do that
yeah that doesn't happen like it used to
now we spend more time with each song
and that all is just Evolution too
because you know you start doing stuff
one way and then slowly your techniques
will change just like painting right you
will learn new things all this cap does
this or you you'll you'll slowly and
everything that you learn becomes a part
of you now you're informed by it but
you're gonna move on and still do
something different but you'll still
drag all that [__] that you learned with
you you know and so and so now this
particular record we did in a way that
we'd never done a record before we um
every song You Hear was made for the
album there are no bonuses there were no
songs that didn't go on there because
what we did is we made it in sequence so
when he gave me the first beat which was
the song okay it's the first song on the
album
I didn't even know necessarily we were
making an album yet you we hadn't really
crossed that threshold like he just said
make something with this I did and then
he was like all right this is the second
song and he gave me the second beat and
then I wrote the second song which is
track two on the album and then I'm like
okay we're making an album and now I
have to figure out all my sciences and
here's how I'm gonna approach this and
whatever whatever but basically every
every song we made we made it in
sequence with how we wanted the album to
go which kind of gave us the chance to
like really instead of just having a
bunch of songs and figuring out I want
to put this one here and this one here
we could listen to it go as we went to
go okay it's got to go over here next or
but also you'll hear running things
through the songs where maybe track
three you'll hear an instrument keep
playing into track four or well like you
were saying I'm saying like yeah yeah
the thing about it too is there's stuff
in there that I don't think listeners
will ever hear because it was just there
for us there's stuff in there oh God
there's Easter eggs yeah that maybe
somebody will or if I talk about it
somebody's might hear you know I'm
saying but for the most part like there
were things involved in it that were
like they're all part of it it's all
encrypted in there for the experience
for us as well as for whoever else I
missed that in hip-hop a lot of times I
mean you just get like a batch of tracks
that I went and did I miss like the
conceptual this is the theme of this
project all these songs are gonna like
blend into that theme in their own way
that's like real Artistry to me I mean
that's you know that's like the late 90s
early 2000s and now here we are 20 years
later
so I don't know maybe we're just
accidentally redoing that because that's
how it all repeats itself you know
because we were doing that kind of [__]
back then you know what I mean with the
with the I mean we all our albums are
concept albums but nobody can hear it
because the concept generally is just me
you know what I mean like oh what am I
thinking about what am I dealing with in
life then musically the concept is him
what sounds does he like right now what
is he into what does he think is I'm
gonna I'm gonna work on this one I'm
gonna you know what I mean so
not to take nothing away from when
people compile songs I like to call
those you know playlists or mixtapes or
what have you it's a normal way to do it
yeah because it because in essence
there's an energy that you do capture
when you make music period And so when
you're making music in that way of
compiling just let me take all the songs
that got there the best ones I'm gonna
put them together now you're handing
somebody this 40 minute
experience of your energies which is
just as dope you know what I'm saying
like I don't think there's a right or
wrong way to do it different approach
yeah so did you get any pushback from
the label once you had this
chronological
Masterpiece or did they say oh no
they're they're so um artist friendly
you know what I'm saying like and yeah
yeah they they trust us we trust them
like really everybody
everybody has got the same intent
they all want to see something happen
that people react to enjoy appreciate
love you know what I'm saying so what
you do is you go okay well I have this
thing here and then everybody now has to
think about and figure out how to
artistically
communicate that to people to you guys
how you guys you know I mean it's like
so every so when it's like that
especially after working together for so
long you know you you understand where
it's going and still there's challenges
things pop up you can't you know life is
different you can't just do the same
thing over and over because it won't
work you know what I'm saying so it's
like even even something like a record
label has to come up with new tricks you
know I'm saying like new things to do in
bed you got to keep coming up with it if
you want to keep the relationship
amazing you know what I'm saying and I
feel like that that that's that's kind
of the situation we've been in for this
long
that's awesome that's what you want out
of your experience with a label I just
don't want to get fired that's all
that's what that's a great job it is the
best job I've ever had you know what I'm
saying so you don't want to get fired
yeah um I got a question just from
listening to you guys music so long what
did you grow up listening to
because some of the [__] you sampled
some of the stuff you do uh one of my
favorite songs is why was it is it why
the Cade Bird Sings that's what it's
called it's on sevens oh yeah yeah that
right yeah that's one of my favorite
songs ever yeah oh really I love that
[__] I don't know why then the screamo
starts oh yeah I love it man that was
definitely him bringing that that's
rainbow style I love to do this one I
don't know why just that's one of the
first albums I ever heard so you know
what's funny about that I've never I
never was really big into rock but that
was around the time I started exploring
rock records and what besides the
sampling like drums in rock you know
that was always a thing but I never was
into rock really and I just started
getting more and more open to it as we
were moving right along and as I
explored other music when I was a kid it
was only Saul and R B and Jazz only
doo-wop and whatnot no no no no I grew
up on like 80s like style in the 70s
stuff you know what I mean uh James
Brown even before that so that's how my
household was and that's all I was about
and so once hip-hop hit and I got into
that and that took over meshed yeah and
it's all Kent it's this it's the same
trajectory you know so I didn't get into
rock and [__] like that until I was like
damn near 30 something years old oh wow
yeah see I grew up on Pink Floyd Led
Zeppelin and yeah James Brown or Little
Anthony because my grandpa and I didn't
listen to the radio so when I found you
guys I was listening to what all the
Living Legends albums MERS out I just
got merger president and somebody said
try atmosphere I was 18 years old I was
insane I told you I was in Santa Cruz
I'm like I'll pick it up I'll try it now
I got God Loves Ugly and overcast and
I'll tell you a little story my second
night of being on my own is when I first
heard you guys put it on I'm like I'm
gonna listen to a couple of tracks I'm
gonna go to sleep I gotta open the pizza
spot in the morning [__] listen to both
albums back to back and I smoked bowls
in my room my second night on my own
ever in my life so I'm like oh what is
this so you guys been there since I've
been an adult so I appreciate that [__]
so I just wanted to ask certain
questions that yeah even when I was
sitting there like what is this what
does that
means that's really dope so as a fan I
got some questions real quick I got a
few just
became I know it's for the fans to
interpret I get that my interpretation
please tell me if I'm wrong or right
it's just friendship going south I mean
sure okay so it's just lets you into it
I mean it is I'll tell you what it is
you know what I'm saying but keep your
interpretation that is good and that's
you know but that's also that's the
important interpretation you know when
you ask an artist where a song came from
and if their story is better than yours
they're lying okay so that song is
actually I ripped it off it was a poem
um that was written by my wife's uncle's
homie and I never really had the chance
to meet that person but I know her uncle
and he told me about this poem about uh
camping with with friends and one of
them became a wolf and ran off in a good
way not in a bad way
um I heard what he told me and then I
interpreted it and took it to where I
took it you know and made it more about
waking up and
um
realizing that your friend is missing
and you're worried about them and then
realizing that your friend is running
with wolves and worrying about them and
then that point that comes for some
people when they realize their friend
has become a wolf and now you have to
worry about them in a different way you
have to fear them you know and that's
where I took it you know because I felt
like
for starters it's a story that I don't
hear you know what I'm saying but it's
it's it's a reality for a lot of us you
know what I'm saying uh you could be the
wolf or you could be the friend but it's
a reality it happens in friendships it
happens in relationships those moments
come where you have to cut somebody off
because they're toxic whatever you feel
me so it's like so that was a story I
just had never heard so when I when I
took the original poem which was also a
beautiful concept you know what I'm
saying but I just took it and and told a
story that was a little bit more
relative to myself because I'm not
really a camping kind of dude
um and so I heard oh this is this is not
he's not really camping and looking for
Footprints but I love that song you know
but I've heard more interpretations
about that song than any other song that
I've ever really which is crazy to me
because it's like some of my songs are
so obtuse and hard to understand that
I'm like yeah yeah you know let me start
with this lighter one and that song is
dope because I got to say um
there's a line in there talking about
you turn into a drumstick like a cartoon
if it was a cartoon like oh man to be
able to actually say that with a
straight face is how it worked it worked
I didn't giggle I I was just listening
storytelling man that's that's music I
mean when it comes to music like that's
my [__] uh my next one uh hair
is this a story you've heard here is a
uh no
no no you see you didn't die in a car
accident no no no nothing of the city
you know there's definitely not a
autobiographical story you know it's
like to me it's just that it's a it's a
story that's sold to a particular
generation 20 year olds that say books
and films the romance of meeting
somebody being into them and then you
[__] die you know what I'm saying and
that's really kind of what it was but I
told it through the lens of somebody who
might have my life right somebody just
got off stage in a small Club
et cetera et cetera but it really it's
not really like a hard story to go for
you know what I mean no no I just wanted
to know because the first time I heard
it because I'm getting built up myself
oh damn you know there's another
question you should be asking about hair
what what is up with part two and part
three because we have that's a
three-part story and all of them are
released but a lot of people have never
put it together but how how is it how is
it more story to after part one I don't
know how familiar you are with our
catalog I'm trying to scan every album
like I have a very photographic
experience in China there's there's on
my Spotify there's two other parts of
the film
and oh my God I'm not in there how about
this if anybody knows don't tell me put
it in the comments for this guy don't
tell me yeah all right all right and
when this releases when you find it
you're gonna be like I can't believe I
never saw this or you might go I can't
believe they bothered making this yeah
it could go either way
but but yeah yeah because because it's
we made it very obvious
ly
I guess I guess you could say the
waitress because she was a waitress
getting off work going to the bar I
could say anything I'm not gonna say
nothing all right I'm gonna listen it's
just kind of fester until you figure it
out but just remember there's three
totals it's good three totals so I got
one you got one yeah
bastard damn it all right I'll I'll
think about that later all right and
then obviously you already know the last
one's gonna ask because this one made my
mom go what the hell is this I go mom
just sit listen it must have been you
no no
because my mom introduced me to
everything in life every Depeche Mode
every single thing you could think of my
mom or for every piece of music I ever
listen to in my life except for well
Anthony or Charles Bradley [__] like
that yeah it's my grandpa yeah uh one
where the tattooed hands my mom goes
what the hell is this ago maybe he's on
acid mom interpreted how you want like I
don't know she didn't like it she was
mad no she was like what is he talking
to him I go just [__] listen
what is he talking about a relationship
like shut up fool that's me what is he
talking about in that song
God
that's what I'm getting I don't know oh
no that's cool I'm with it I was
expecting more than one word I'm trying
to inter because it's so hard to
interpret that I went what does this
mean and I'm listening to it going eh
maybe one day go to a show I'll ask but
never did I think I'd be able to sit
down and go
what does this mean like personally I
don't know it's all left up into
interpretation I get it's art but to the
person what does it mean to you when
you're writing go
[__] when you're done I know you went
damn that was intense so I've told the
story about where that song came from
numerous times and I don't even think
the story is that important anymore
um I've that's the song that I've heard
people interpret for me for now over 20
years you know and my new reaction to
people asking me what that song is about
is something that I came up with
yesterday actually oh damn and
um it's a joke I heard and I'm going and
I rewrote the joke to make it mine to
own it because that's what we do
um and so I will answer that song for
your mom if she wants to know what the
hell it's about
atheism the original non-profit
organization
I like that ah
that's not the punch line the punch line
is it's the original non-profit
organization yeah
okay okay I got you no I get it I get it
also guys I'm sorry I got kind of stoked
I have joints roll do you guys want to
join oh man
um I mean Sports if not no worries you
got other [__] to do
I thought it kind of smelled like sound
set in here I was like like sound
setting here so I have joined it's up to
you guys or just take them for later
there I'll take it I'll take it for
later for sure you know what I'm gonna
give it to the pilot when we fly home
I'm gonna be like hey bro hey hey hey
Smoke his ass for you this is for you if
you guys you guys mind oh yeah no go for
it yeah okay okay
what's your the song the song tattooed
hands is um is is just about trying to
figure out what you believe in you know
what I'm saying like honestly because
she is presenting both and I'm like well
which one is the one or what is it or is
it a good versus evil or what's going on
and I ultimately Just Bounce I don't
even commit because I'm scared of
commitment so that's that's that's what
the song is about that's where I was
that's what I wanted I I I'm sorry for
the joke no I'm sorry for the joke hey
man I'm gonna figure out how to tell
that [__] so it's funny though
you're funny your whole life but only
half of it people like I agree now yeah
yeah okay that's cool that's why I like
we did this for 10 years it just started
working two years ago I just did it
because it's [__] fun and make people
smile if you're smiling I'm still oh
this is the same way with us we I mean
[__] we I had regular job until I was
35. I was a janitor 2005 matter of fact
where listen we were selling records and
this dude was still doing janitor work
because it was like why stop the hustle
you feel me it's like yeah that's how I
always see the job it's a job yeah yeah
but it was like it just seemed like the
right thing to do you know what I mean
um so when you actually we did 15 years
ago when uh Life Community limbs came
out yeah I was gonna say I quit my job
no I quit a few years before that but it
was still new like this was all like you
quit your job in 2005 yeah to go on tour
yeah yeah so his first tour with me so
he didn't really even take a break he
went from janitoring to dropping [__]
and it was funny too because the funny
thing about that [__] is
in two ways my jokes sucked my jokes
you're good it's great you know the
funny thing is is uh
um when I went on that tour because he
was like you know I would I want to put
more a little more DJing stuff into the
band stuff so now or never and I was
like I probably should try it you know
what I mean I really did you talk about
I'm very
not a social person so I was like oh man
but I gotta try this right so I told my
job all right two months and I'm gonna
come back and all that and then we went
out in two months that time of my life
changed my world he told me to it was
like it's gonna change your life I was
like yeah whatever you know went out and
it changed my life and I got back and I
was supposed to go back to work and I
was just like oh man I'm gonna wait a
couple days before I go back to work
because I had to decompress man I was on
tour yeah tour is a weird thing at first
I was like man then I called and they
were like oh we filled your position and
I was like
thank God yeah I mean like yeah yeah I
didn't have to do nothing you know they
were like yeah they were like we know
you're not coming back you know well
good because I'm [__] glad this
happened man it was great but then I
called him up I was like can I keep this
uh DJ [__]
he's like yeah I was like well I'll let
you try out I'm gonna have tryouts
yeah it was awesome so ever since yeah
well I'm glad this happened it always
works that way I like what was it easy
put this damn glasses on all right I
feel good let's go out there there's
always something like you you're the
glass just like get your ass out here
yeah man it's something that and they
like I didn't talk on camera until six
years into doing [__] I was I don't want
to talk on camera my voice I'm wearing
my own voice yeah and then I'm like yeah
let's try it it's it's weird I don't go
to parties I'm the guy in the back
smoking joints and I leave and say I
showed up man I promise oh man yeah I
hate I hate it even though I'm super
social when I need to be yeah so I feel
you on that aspect I've definitely grown
a tour has taught me that you know what
I mean like I've like oh [__] it I'm
starting to figure out my Lane yeah and
all these people like yo appreciate you
guys so happy to be here like that
that's got to give you a little like
yeah pip right yeah if you're when
you're told you're doing a great job
every day it's like come on it's hard
not to like yeah it makes it easy good
job again
really I never heard that for like the
first 30 years of my life
yeah that's a great point I never even
thought of this like you know I mean
like here every day I really think about
that like all our fans whenever they say
like that really is fuel when things are
tough or you're like just going through
a lot of [__] like that really is like
extra backup fuel hell yeah it makes you
still deep when you're like yeah yeah
it's just not selling right like but
people are happy yeah you got to be
happy with that it's amazing yeah very
very fortunate is weed been a part of
your guys process the whole time
yeah I mean mine
you know
um Define process you mean lighting life
it's like that you know and so it's it's
not always part of the writing of the
recording you know just like it's not
always part of
riding in an airplane and it's not
always yeah like yeah but it's always
been present yeah I'm saying weed and
sugar we didn't yeah there you go
um
what did you what's your top three
movies top three favorite movies I like
to ask this for guests but
it's not like you're you're sitting at
reference and [__] in yourself you know
when some artists but I at least know
they like this direction of something I
don't think I've ever heard of reference
dropped or none of that uh ball pop
culture with the arms and feet thing so
I always thought like yo I wonder what
the hell this fool likes what did you
grow up watching what's your favorite
movies it's not my favorite but this
dude basically has to bribe me not to
make Star Wars references in the songs
because there's always hidden there's
always hidden Star Wars like like now
that I've said that you'll realize that
there's a lot of them yeah like yeah
yeah now we've got it down all right
wants a record all right once an album
yeah
um it's hard to say favorite films it's
hard to say favorite books I can't I
don't know how to say favorite albums so
what I could say is movies that I've
seen more than other movies there you go
Purple Rain hands down I've seen that
movie more than any other movie In My
Life
um and then after that I would say
Training Day
and then after that I would say you know
it's it's probably one of the Star Wars
movies
specifically now with you know a bunch
of kids it's like oh you end up
revisiting movies that you saw when you
were younger and then seeing them again
and again so I think that having kids
bumped up the Star Wars numbers for me
yeah I have too many I'm crazy about a
lot of stuff but and my go-to has always
been Godfather it was just the easy one
to say all three months right yeah yeah
well definitely one and two but uh
Apocalypse Now actually a great movie
it's the same director but uh man that
movie
it's it it influenced a lot of what I do
uh mood wise and you might not it's just
like half the time I'm making music I
see the colors of that movie in my head
it's pretty trippy yeah I I just love
that movie and I recently
you know hearts of Darkness there's a is
a dog you've seen that no it's a it's a
documentary made at the time but his
wife filmed a documentary Making the
movie and that's amazing that's an
amazing movie but there's also
Francis Ford Coppola talking over
Apocalypse Now yeah the commentary It's
[__] amazing it's brilliant and
matter of fact if you're on YouTube
right now check that out after this it's
pretty amazing it's just like all the
details and all the things he talks
about it's like Artistry times ten you
know what I mean it's just like all the
little nip the little facts
you know I never saw that I just saw it
on YouTube I was like I just I ran into
it because I had seen the hearts of
Darkness uh thing and I was like oh man
she's way too good like man yeah so when
I when the commentary thing showed up I
was like ah let me try it out for a
second and I just was like in it anyway
no that's crazy Apocalypse Now I just
wanted to know like I asked this to a
lot of guests because you kind of get
the feel if you say in Purple Rain for
is great my mom I watched that when I
was like maybe four I didn't understand
why like he was the like you know when
you see every other movie I watched
Gaston and beauty Beast beating Fool's
ass like I get I guess I give my [__]
like him but my mom is a purp is a
prince fanatic so as a kid I'm like the
guy with the the guy dressed like a girl
you like I was three four and then I I
get it the music I'm like
uh when I hit like five or six I
understood like oh he's just prince I
get it like I'm a dude but I I get it so
when you say Purple Rain like his little
leg going over that motorcycle to get on
stay here you know as a kid that [__]
was sick as hell that was Tiny too so I
get it
I heard you refer to music maybe I'm
misconstrued as like colors do you it's
an actual condition there's a name for
it where like producers people in music
actually see different music in
different colors in their mind yeah I
feel like I'm like that I associate like
color palettes with different beats do
you do that [__] what the hell uh it
kind of gives you like a Vibe or like a
yeah I know a few people that like that
and he's like that too for sure yeah oh
okay yeah I was gonna ask is that like
part of
because you're starting from scratch
each time you go into a new beat
essentially right yeah well not
generally when I just start messing up
I'm just there's nothing there I'm just
blank you know usually I'm using there's
something that's inspired me I'm for
sure but I do it every day I just turn
something on and just whatever happens
it's not always worth hearing but it's
just what I do
and then a color starts forming and then
I just I just starts that's how I see it
what are your main tools that you use
like my main thing is I still sample the
way I always have since the early 90s
um still records and DJing and stuff but
now
oh I have a lot of synthesizers I'll
play certain things and obviously I have
musicians I work with some genius genius
musicians uh Big Ups jiko Graham
Richards them dudes and uh other people
too but those two
has changed my life yeah so it's just
every day you're basically in the studio
just creating every day no matter what's
going on yeah yeah every day yep every
single day and there's days I don't want
to like I'll just I'll like
oh man nothing but then that's the day
I'm like well just turn it on just turn
it on play some SOS band and just hang
out and then you'll you'll find you'll
find the mood you know what I mean I'll
find the mood to do something
that's that's what happens wow yeah um I
got a question
you guys
were you the one uploading YouTube
trying to find a balance was a 16 year
ago upload I that's when YouTube
basically was starting you guys have
been on YouTube that video has been on
there since YouTube started essentially
did you guys that's why we got so many
views on that one too much I mean there
was three videos on YouTube it was
trying to find a balance there was that
one beer can or bacon video thing and
then you know what I mean like and
there's this it was the third one that
had a cat with a hula hoop cat is when
the cat videos changed the Earth yeah so
okay so when I saw it I go that's a 16
years I did that's when YouTube
basically started I didn't even know
that though so you guys were on it back
then have you ever thought of just uh
re-uploading it like with a re-edited or
remastered like an anniversary version
because it's back when YouTube was like
this it's a little box when you watch it
oh wow is that even if you can't even
blow it I don't really watch the videos
so I don't know what none of them really
look like I just read the comments I I
think
I think uh
I I don't know I never considered
remastering a YouTube video as you
imagine happy anniversary repackaged
remastered we have talked about doing
this as a joke it's coming back to the
commentary we've done it we've talked
joked about doing commentary on having
videos and just playing on all our
videos and just talking I didn't see you
guys released with you guys talking over
even if it's back to you in the garage
come on we were we considered we
considered actually putting like
uploading streams of us talking over a
whole album where it would be like all
of life gives you lemons with us talking
over it put that on the streaming
platforms just for the just for the
taste of it you know what I'm saying
like yeah yeah just do one and then you
guys will get the response that you need
see it's really fun to joke about but
then it's like okay so then I'm gonna
need you guys to come over on Thursday
so we and then that's the part where I
go ah
I would rather just write a new song I
would rather spend Thursday writing a
new song than spend Thursday trying to
repackage some old [__] you know what I
mean yeah the way you'd put it and even
listening to the old [__] too is kind of
it's just it's tough yeah because you
move on and you just go what am I gonna
do next you know what what else can I
fail at how can I how can I go back and
fix that thing
foreign
I mean like anything
um if I have the time you know
like we got kids we got life going on
but if I have the time to go if I have
three hours then I'm gonna write not
because I have to not because I'm like
oh I'm agonizing I have to write but
because it's what I love to do so if I
can sneak away and go down to the
basement for three hours plus because
I'll do three to Thirty I will that's
what I would rather be doing you know
what I'm saying like I'd rather do that
than watch TV I'd rather do that than
watch a movie again you know what I mean
it's but with that said sometimes you go
and you're like ah
I'm not really angry at nothing what am
I supposed to write about
what am I supposed to do
you know I will say this in recent years
with the with the technique that we're
painting with right now now that he
gives me a beat and I force myself to
deal with that beat I don't stop until I
have dealt with it whether it's
something good or something horrible I'm
going to complete this song for better
for worse now that that's the thing
writing is a lot a lot easier if that
makes any sense not easier but but it's
like getting it going because now I'm
like okay well he gave me this I gotta
do something where they whereas back in
the day maybe I'd get a folder full of
beads or whatever and then you would
just be like what about this one and
what about this one too many options now
I get this one beat and I'm just like ah
you know what I'm gonna write about cars
and nobody he's ever going to hear it
but at least I got [__] at least I had
it now at least I got it spinning I got
things moving you know what I'm saying
and I had a good time you know what I
mean like and the other thing is for me
with writing is
I'm by myself mostly sometimes he's
around but I would say for 90 of the
time I write all alone not another
person in the room just me so I'm
allowed to be as vulnerable as I want to
be and that's a weird word but no it
makes sense it's the word and then if I
hear it and I'm not embarrassed to hear
it I give it to him to hear and if I'm
not embarrassed to let him hear it then
I know okay I can be this vulnerable in
front of people you know what I'm saying
it's like and so with that said that all
of that is all a part of my process now
when I write I'm I get to write about
whatever I want I get to write about
anything but the rule is it's got to be
some [__] that I actually understand I
can't just be Googling and writing about
you know
science you know what I'm saying it's
like it has to be something I know you
know what I mean like and so writing is
a easier is not the right word because
it's not like it's simpler to do but
it's easier to get into it's easier to
throw myself into the job because yeah
it's just wide open you know that makes
sense yeah do either of you foresee ever
utilizing any AI Tools in music making
writing it's going to come to a day
where you say I want to Up Tempo beat
that sounds like this person's style
that has such and such BPM click all
those elements sound like that
everything that I like doing so what
that yeah
then so like someone wrote for you yeah
to each his own but uh you know I also
think you can never say never I guess
because I remember when I very first
started DJing and making beats and stuff
in the 80s I never would have thought I
would use a computer you know what I
mean like okay when I was in high school
computer was an elective class that I
didn't take yeah I mean so it was kind
of like you know whatever you know so
now here we are I can actually do the
[__] you know on a computer it's scary
to me like I'm a graphic artist like it
could essentially put graphic artists
out of business or be your greatest tool
like you're gonna have to figure out how
to utilize it and figure out the skills
around when you're an artist like Bend
because yeah you know like like any art
that challenges Commerce and back and
forth the truth is this
the best rapper is broke
the best graphic artist is starving
so as a graphic artist and as a rapper
it's not that AI is going to be better
than us that should be our concern
because there's people out there better
than you that don't have your careers
and that's just art and commerce you
know
um your goal is how to present this to
people how to communicate this to people
that's the thing that is in the way of
everybody you know otherwise all art
would be available for us to see but the
truth is it comes down to how it's
presented and given the opportunity to
be in front of people's faces you know
and so that's really your battle with AI
with this art [__] it's not really that
and this is just all opinion I really
have no idea I just thought of this
right now yeah um I but I think that
it's it's not about it's not about AIA
taking your job because it's better than
you because there's hell of people
better than you you know what I'm saying
it's more about how are you positioning
yourself to ensure that you can
communicate to these people you know
what I'm saying and so I don't AI can
take that I don't think that you know I
think like we saw a robot delivering
food today yeah and and it was like I
just you know he took ubereats his job
it's a delivery job and so on and so
forth like shit's always gonna there's
always stuff but you gotta figure out
how to work in that how to work around
that how to work alongside that because
it's here you know I I can't remember
who but it's some [__] I read a long
time ago like Humanity's [__] is all
about convenience and quality of life
how can you be I don't say as lazy as
possible but let's break it down to that
how can you be as lazy as possible but
still get over it and that's what
technology is that's what technology is
for is to make you have the ability to
have as much fun as possible be as lazy
as possible so so we're here we're doing
it so figure out how to work within it
you know what I mean like that's a great
plan the robot too it looks like a
lunchbox it does it looks like that
Wally
remembering Star Wars the one box with
the feet
yeah and a little bit small Star Wars
reference I did you got one in yeah I
was like dang I wonder if you can just
open this here as it's going by oh so
you're a Star Wars fan I got something
for you you'll [__] like what is it
I'm not a huge Star Wars guy watching
when I was a kid I watched the old ones
right I'm from Merced California yeah uh
it's by Modesto you know uh
what the hell is his name the guy that
writes oh George George Lucas oh yeah
yeah I was saying lucasfilms George
Lucas he's from adesto which is not far
we're the gateway to Yosemite I was
delivering pizza I had an old school I
have 86 Monte Carlo like a kind of like
a training day looks like it but it's
not the Grand National Regal but yeah
I'm driving it's my parking lot my pizza
spot I'm about to open I'm [__]
smoking a joint I'm going to the gas
station
and then
as I'm going to the oh I just quit the
pizza spot it was right there and I see
this old man with a beard on a
motorcycle with chaps and glasses and
like chaps and glasses and the button up
all right [__] yeah old man and he's
typing on his phone I tried by and he
looks every old man looks at me goes
because the car yeah so I always imagine
every every older man that looks at me
is like
so I see him he's looking at me like
I'm like what I'm just driving but he's
looking at me like what do you want I'm
like okay and I go to the gas station
it's closed I'm like for real I come
back through and I look at him and as I
cross he's like kind of like do you want
a picture I'm like no and I stop and I'm
like that is [__] George Lucas and I
look at him oh [__] holy [__] it's
[__] George Lucas in Merced like I
wish it was more of a Star Wars fan I
would be like yo
but I remember I saw like my homie is a
fanatic and I'm like I I see him not you
this is sad but yeah George Lucas is mad
cool and he rides Harleys with chaps you
never would have thought yeah he rides
with chaps that's it that's my only
[__] Star Wars thing I ever had I
like the what do you [__] want man
that's what he looked at me like you
want a picture and I looked him like you
want to take pictures too hard he's all
old men hey
let me take a picture
yeah
that's because they always do a little
small town cheried-ass car like I I did
old man you gotta cross the streams and
be like hey would you like to take a
picture of you in my car yeah you know
what I mean you want me be like a a Star
Wars character for you which one would
you be you know which one it would be
no that's [__] up I'm not gonna make
fun he goes by dope is Yola so last year
last year you guys bong in his hand and
the ears no I want to be Harrison Ford
my kids told me a joke they saw on the
internet about me bringing up Yoda
um
it was like it was like a meme about
like uh describe a movie in like five
words and it was a picture of you know
Luke Skywalker with Yoda on his back and
it said um
[Laughter]
swamp frog convinced his kid to kill his
dad or some [__]
talking
frog convinces kid to kill his dad
thought that was funny it's dead on
exactly what happened if you want to
break it I got another one of the jokes
that my kids are telling right now the
little kid the five-year-old says
um oh man this one was good too he's
like
do you want to get babies to stop crying
on airplanes
stop making them think airplanes get
eaten
what do you guys yeah yeah oh
psychological yeah oh it's a joke though
no it's not that deep
it's not that deep but
damn man I'm sorry for the swinging
misses on these I'm over here
timing
it's what I'm doing is I'm here working
it out oh yeah I'm saying that's what
this is for yeah but I'll say this this
is this is also this is also like older
guys talking about their kids at this
point but since he said that my kid on
an airplane my son five years old two or
four at the time
taking he never been on an airplane that
he can remember anyway we're taking off
and he goes man this is better than
riding on the dragon oh sick
because you know he's imaginative yeah
yeah yeah I did it's been on dragons but
this [__]
he has three kids I have no kids so I
live through FaceTime like what's up
little child you grow and like make
jokes to this fool and then she's
getting so big it's so weird but uh yeah
man I'm not ready for that but you guys
yeah take your time on that [__] oh yeah
yeah yeah I'm on a way to slowly yeah
yeah yeah yeah stay
healthy responses as long as you can
yeah no dude I still want to like smoke
a joy in my hallway and walk around and
look at pictures yeah yeah yes smoke I
always say I went from directly from
hiding weed from my mod I hiding weed
from my kids yeah
it's very true if you want to break
these down
um I know you guys are on time limits I
understand I know we're at past your
time and stuff but real quick album
Where can everybody get it where can
everybody grab it is it on obviously you
check it on Spotify but if they want to
grab it you said you can get hard copies
you can get oh yeah I have a website
um what's it called atmospheresucks.com
and it's like all our merch
atmospheresucks.com love it yeah it's
got all our merch it's got links to get
to listening stuff it's got but also
it's when I say my it's because I put up
personal stuff on there there's all
kinds of stuff that I write and pictures
that I put oh wait no no no actually I
should say eBay one it's just merch uh
all this shit's there you know but you
could stream it I'm sure everywhere that
things are stripped
I like that stress the new one strength
and then what about live performances
after that we'll be on tour uh May 5th
the record comes out and then just a few
days later we start in London
um run around Europe for a couple of
weeks then we come home and and and hit
um Alaska and Colorado and uh Monterey
Monterey yep and then um and then in
early July we go on a longer tour with
slightly stupid and Sublime with Rome
and the movement and we'll be out with
them for the remainder of the summer and
then there's probably some more stuff
coming up you know usually you try to
get out there and move around with
people as much as possible before you
get old
yeah it's good advice it's gonna be a
busy year yeah yeah is there anywhere
that you really like look forward to
when you go out on the road is there
like a particular country or city you
know I don't know I like I really there
isn't anywhere I don't look forward to
you know and I feel fortunate for that
because there's nowhere that I'm like
what we gotta go there it's awesome is
there I can't even think because
everybody's got record stores and so
and so we go there and we visit the
record store I love it and then uh play
a show for some people that came out to
smile you know what I mean so so
everywhere is pretty fun I guess my
favorite place to play would probably be
you know West Coast uh the mountain
states I love playing The Mountain
States as well
um I love the Midwest I love the East
Coast
I love Florida
I love I love I love performance shows
in in in in Texas it kind of goes back
to what we were saying earlier like when
you're when people come in to see you
and tell you you did a good job like how
can you be mad at that no matter where
you are if there's even only a 50 people
at your show it doesn't who gives a [__]
you know well I got to hear that that
means you just love it no matter what
like even if I never made money in a lot
I could still love I love to write you
say awake if I can get away and just
right so you guys are passion like yeah
as a fan it's I'm stupid it's no court
of life and that's who you are when
you're an artist like that and this cult
following you guys have built is
is forever when we're [__] all 90
it's still going to be there so that's
the whole point and I know uh like I
said I know the time's out and I waited
Marty knows I did pretty well guys
you guys are my favorite group of all
time oh Mac Dre slug all-time favorite
we've been preaching online for 10 years
so for this I'm glad I got through the
whole thing but guys thank you very much
this has been very [__] awesome for
me listen I appreciate you guys and I I
appreciate uh the length of time that
you have spent dedicated to listening to
our [__] it means a lot
um you are officially a lifer and so
with that we're gonna get you like a
little punch card a membership oh yeah
and then every time that you go to a
show you get a punch and then after like
10 punches you get punched oh [__] let's
just say some high fives I landed one
you got one you got it
guys thank you so much for being here
appreciate it May 5th thank you oh oh no
I have it over there I got you but I got
a bunch of stuff for you guys all right
thank you guys so much for being here I
appreciate it appreciate you super
stoked guys this is in the atmosphere
episode and slug thank you so much for
being here here from Marty from me have
a dope ass day
thanks for watching the podcast if you
thought this was dope you'll like this
episode too and don't forget the best
way to support the show tell a homie